yesterday elon musk came out and he said
he's selling cyber whistles everyone
knows elon has been doing this for years
basically i don't know if it's once a
year or once every couple years but he
comes out with a product and he says
tesla's gonna be selling this thing
yesterday was the cyber whistle so the
cyber whistle is a whistle it is uh a
whistle in the shape of the cyber truck
i don't know if any cyber trucks are out
yet or getting delivered or even maybe
yet but we got whistles so you can buy
the whistle online and he said don't
waste your money on that silly apple
cloth buy our whistle instead
which is just genius level trolling
right there because uh for those that
don't know apple came out with what was
it a twenty dollar uh basically like a
cloth it was a micro climber screen yeah
microfiber cloth that you would use to
clean your screen they got trolled a lot
uh turns out they're selling a lot of
them but eli came out with his own
product controlled them what do we think
john elon's the troll master he gets
marketing more better i think than on
everyone else he absolutely has a
massive following that he's pushing
these products to i'm not really sure if
like this is to make money but it's just
interesting to see there are no cyber
trucks delivered yet so he's even
trolling himself saying go buy our cyber
whistle you'll get it before the cyber
truck yeah and i think the other thing
to think about right is he he's done
this in the past he did liquor uh which
he famously took the picture outside of
the tesla and were saying they were
going bankrupt then he followed it up
with doing some liquor in a cool bottle
he did the short shorts right to make
fun of the shorts uh and now he's doing
the cyber truck whistle and making fun
of apple so i think yeah the joke is
obviously one part of it but he he's
obviously he knows how to play the
internet in my opinion right he's got a
strong strong strong community that not
only believes in tesla but him
specifically as an entrepreneur with
everything he's doing outside of tesla
with spacex and other companies so i
think he understands it better than
anyone
look they're sold out already i don't
know how many they sold and maybe
someone in the chat knows uh if he
announced it but my my understanding is
they don't actually announce how many
they've sold uh but there's no more
eligible to be buy so that makes me
think that he's not doing it to create
some kind of you know alternate revenue
stream they make plenty of money on cars
their stock price is done very very well
this year i don't think he's necessarily
looking to start getting into physical
products monetizing through his twitter
account but who knows i think it's just
another asset to add to the community to
get people riled up online and poke some
phone at competitors like apple i mean
genius loved marketing he marketed the
shorts at 69 and
42 cents he literally said six nine four
twenty and if you notice that all this
stuff is selling out within minutes
right so people are flooding to his
website flying to traffic and he knows
when he tweets pretty much anything it
gets thousands and thousands of likes um
so it's incredible to see the following
that he's created over the last 10 20
years building spacex building tesla and
building all these other companies
including paypal as well well i would
say uh i made a mistake
you ready i forgot about the
flamethrower
the boring company also has a
flamethrower as well i forgot about the
flamethrower the flamethrower was legit
if anyone knows how to get our hands on
one of those let us know the union is in
the market this is what we use our dues
for
it's for flamethrowers we'll bring it in
the studio we'll spray it around
hopefully no fire but look he was like
let's get back to this yeah he also the
tesla decanter that looked like a
lightning bolt has created a massive
falling and the people that buy it are
literally just buying it because of elon
musk there was someone who tweeted yeah
you can see it here for 150 you can buy
a tesla decanter that basically has no
liquor in it at all it's just a
glass-shaped lightning oh [ __ ] so i was
wrong i thought it was like an actual
liquor bottle that he just like filled
with some like partner with some liquor
company it's literally just a decanter
then you fill it up with your own yup
that's legendary and he's got people
buying it someone tweeted uh mr tweeted
i don't even drink alcohol and then i
had to google what a decanter is and he
bought one he's literally just like look
these products are amazing that he can
sell these products to individuals
without even knowing without even really
liking the product he's just selling it
to sell it at this point what do you
think about uh uh his like the community
of people that follow him
do you have an opinion on like whether
uh there's like there's like elon musk
maximalist basically yeah they're like
he elon can do no wrong kind of deal um
i don't i see a problem with being like
the maximus that extent of like your
opinion can change over time so you have
to be weary of that but he's obviously
done a excellent job of marketing
himself and the businesses he's built
are incredible right i'm a big believer
in tesla big believer in spacex um
paypal is obviously a massive business
as well and every other venture he's
done the porn company sells
flamethrowers and they probably sold out
of those too so i actually like the
people that follow him um and i tweeted
the other day which i still think is
relevant is just don't bet against elon
musk yeah i i my general take on this
kind of stuff is that uh i don't think
he should be treated like a god right
like there's some subset of the people
that like him that treat him uh like he
is better than anything else in the
world and you know
they throw everything they have in it
maybe that's one percent maybe that's
five percent maybe that's 10 but there's
a there's a percentage of people that do
that i think that's weird kind of
sketchy like don't be doing that around
me that's weird as hell but then there's
a subset of people who just generally
root for him right and he's a person
that i would root for because he's doing
really really cool stuff right he's
doing what kids dream of right which is
building rockets building cars doing
things
yeah trying to go out to uh different
planets and and build life on other on
other planets and i think that's really
cool so i think that
my whole thing with elon musk is like i
never got why anyone root against him
right and there's a part of it that like
yeah the government has tricked some
people into believing that taxing him
would solve all our problems which it
won't uh but even if you think okay
maybe he shouldn't have as much money as
he has or maybe he should do this or
that first off it's not your money so
let him do whatever the hell he wants as
long as he's following the rules second
off uh i don't get how you would bet
against someone who's clearly trying to
advance and innovate and move our
society forward right he's literally
trying to put people to live on other
planets should something happen here or
should we need a multi-uh planetary
living right so i think in that context
it's really cool and i wouldn't bet
against him but i saw a video uh the
other day from a 60 minutes interview he
did which i don't know if anyone's seen
this but he haven't seen it i would
recommend go checking it out
and essentially what it was was i think
it was in 2012 or something like that or
2013 and they were they were doing a 60
minutes interview about spacex and they
were saying hey you know neil armstrong
uh buzz all these guys said that they
don't believe in what you're doing
taking commercial flights to space and
trying to get regular individuals out
into space and they think it's uh they
think it's reckless they think you
shouldn't be doing all of this and he
almost looks like he was gonna cry like
literally he looked like really really
really sad and it was really sad to see
because you could tell like it meant a
lot to him uh those guys he's like yeah
those were my heroes it was very
upsetting to see them and then it turned
and the guy was like so did you ever
think about quitting and he just goes no
and they were like what do you mean and
he's like something along the lines of
like i'll never give up i'd have to be
either dead or incapacitated basically
and literally that was like his mindset
and he went from like crying and a flip
of a switch he just looked angry and was
like why would you ever think i would
give up and that's the kind of mindset
that i think inspires a lot of people
and maybe that convinces some people to
treat him like a god i don't think
that's the right thing to do uh but i
never understood why people would bet
against him what's the story about him
when he sold his paypal shares he had
what like 500 million dollars and put it
into all these different companies and
claims that he borrowed money for rent
like just don't bet against elon musk
the guy has gone out on a win multiple
times he's been on himself over and over
again and he's built massive companies
and a massive following on the internet
and he might be the ultimate troll
someone just commented and said pomp is
out here posting on his ig on his off
day
shake my effing head he's posted on ig
right now
i thought this guy was like running to
the office that's what he made us think
he's on his way here but but but but he
was clear we're gonna have a
conversation about the ig later
[Laughter]
okay uh oh so well first off are you
buying one of these whistles or did you
buy a whistle i'm not buying a whistle i
have no need for a whistle that looks
like a cyber truck i'm not i would like
a cyber truck but i'm not buying one